bonsoir alors écoutez on va parler de
solo star wars story le dernier film de
star wars et qui vient tout juste de
sortir aujourd'hui ou demain si vous
avez des vidéos demain peu importe etc
alors je vais essayer de faire une
partie sans spoil et avec ce pôle
cette fois ci parce que je pense que
beaucoup aimeraient avoir aussi une
critique sans spoil
enfin une critique moi je pense pas
faire vraiment une critique mais
j'exprime mon avis donc voilà essayant
d'échangés là-dessus j'adore faire ce
genre de vidéo je vous partage mon avis
sur un film juste après l'avoir vu parce
que tout simplement
j'aime échanger après avoir vu d'un film
et j'aime faire des débats avec vous
donc ça me fait kiffer alors voix
écoutée on va commencer direct alors
qu'est ce que j'ai pensé de ce film
alors sans spoil on va pas se polluer
j'essaie de dire le moins de choses
possibles à être compliqué mais je ne
vais pas spoiler vous en faites pas donc
déjà solostar war stories du coup c'est
un film spin off sur la vie de hann solo
comme vous le savez donc c'était un film
où je n'attendais rien
j'y suis allé vraiment en mode je
n'attends rien j'étais pas aller voir au
cinéma
rogan et au final j'avais pas
spécialement regretté puis je les ai vus
plus tard et puis j'avais bien aimé mais
c'était pas non plus le meilleur film
alors après c'était que des nouveaux
personnages intégré et cetera
c'était avait pas de quoi se rattacher
vraiment c'était juste se rattacher au
bout de mission qui était la mission
gogoan là c'est différent on s'attache
directement au personnage puisqu'il
s'agit de anne solo joué par du coup
alden ehrenreich et du coup on a déjà
une base en fait on connaît déjà une
solo connais déjà chewbacca mais
pourtant c'est pas des personnages dont
je suis réellement fans dont je suis
j'aime beaucoup chewbacca de saman solo
voilà je t'aime bien mais c'est pas non
plus le meilleur personnage c'est un peu
sans
sans avis quoi je les aime bien mais
voilà c'est un solo c'est un personnage
de star wars mais ce n'est pas mon
préféré quoi et pourtant j'ai surkiffé
le film mais vraiment j'ai vachement
bien aimé le film j'étais à fond du
début à la fin j'ai pas vu le temps
passer
j'ai vraiment sûr qui fait alors le
casting était et est vraiment pas mal il
y avait que des grosses têtes quand même
du cinéma donc alden ehrenreich donc moi
qui je trouve joue très bien en solo
parce que du coup c'est vrai que c'était
compliqué on connaissait déjà en solo un
petit peu jeunes sur tatouine via star
wars 4 et c'était pour moi compliqué de
mettre un autre acteur qui en solo que
par don harrison ford pour 1 2 solo et
franchement c'était vachement bien alden
ehrenreich il a une il a vraiment tout
pour ce rôle en fait il joue extrêmement
bien le jour le en solo mais jeunes gens
nous on voit bien de solo voilà il est
contre bondit les filous il est malin il
fait toujours ses petites histoires ses
petites affaires et ses terrains et lui
joue vachement bien le côté intrépide en
plus le côté
voilà je jeune je fais des conneries
j'ai pas conscience de tous mais en même
temps il ya le côté en solo qui sait ce
qu'il fait et c est surtout alden
ehrenreich il a une vraiment il a la
bonne gueule quoi c'est vraiment le mec
à la bonne gueule exactement pour un
solo qu'à la grande gueule là la bonne
figure pour jouer ce personnage c'est
genre de personnage et tu le vois en
fait en train de faire le con enfin en
train de faire le hand solo quoi tu as
envie de sourire en fait dès que tu vois
ça gueule tu en as envie de sourire en
mode cutting suffit là c'est un sacré
malin et j'ai vraiment j'ai vraiment
kiffé ça et je trouve qu'il joue
vachement bien le rôle il voyage a rien
d'autre à dire là dessus de plus alors
on a eu aussi
alors du coup j'ai noté les noms parce
que je me rappelle plus du tout mais
genre woody harrelson qui est pareil
un grand acteur qui joue à beckett un
personnage principal du film si vous
n'avez pas vu un personnage un peu
mentor de han solo qui va rencontrer au
fil de l'histoire et
pareil qui son personnage est très est
très attachant tout ça et séraphin non
franchement il est vachement bien
et puis surtout je vais en parler après
ce qu'il ya avant il ya c'est vrai qu'il
ya un truc je m'étais pas rendu compte
mais qui est assez incroyable
donald glover dans le rôle de landeleau
alors ils disent dans le film callari
science ça ça m'a fait un peu bizarre
pour moi je dis quelle riche jan parce
que voilà je sais pas où je dis qu'elle
a réussi à passer à l'anglais et ce quoi
vous je sais pas si c'est parce que
c'est des voix françaises dont ils
disent qu'à la région donald glover quoi
le genre j'ai pas réalisé au début ça
m'a fait extrêmement bizarre parce que
j'avais pas capté au début je me faisait
marrer ce mec là je le connais il a une
tête ça me revient et tout bien moment
je sais pas pourquoi j'ai pensé à la
musique de this is america et ses
sommets rica et du coup je suis non se
produit je dois dire de la merde tout ça
faut sort soit ça de la tête c'est pas
lui puis après du coup je rentre du coup
il ya genre quinze minutes je vérifie
donald glover la vidéomusique genre la
musique a fait qu est devenue un mème
tout ça c'était lui alors ça fait très
très bizarre parce que du coup tu te
passe de la musique laudau puis du coup
je vais reverrai fille tu passes de
landeleau asie 6 america tu dis [ __ ]
[ __ ] ça fait bizarre et c'était
c'était très marrant et en tout cas il a
bien joué son rôle
mais on reviendra dessus plus dans le
côté spoiler et puis enfin évidemment
emilia clarke à emilia clarke [ __ ] les
mecs milhas clark
je reste sans voix à chaque fois parce
que immédiat clark genre c'est mon idéal
féminin en fait genre emilia clarke l
est
elle est trop belle [ __ ] genre mais
vraiment je vous dis quand je vous dis
que c'est mon idéal féminin
c'est incroyable cette meuf et du coup
je jure je buvais son rôle en fait
durant j'étais à fond dedans j'étais à
fond dans son personnage tout sa
terrasse etc et je m'attendais pas du
tout à ce type de personnage au départ
ce que du coup on va peut-être venir
plus sur le côté spoil mais je
m'attendais pas du tout à ce genre de
personnage et franchement j'ai vachement
bien aimé son rôle j'ai vachement gagner
mais sa façon de jouer j'ai pas trouvé
ça parce que du coup en fait j'ai eu un
petit a priori du coup une petite
dédicace a game of les mauves théorie ci
passe par là qui m'avait dit que bon
emilia clarke en dehors de game of
thrones a jamais été très folichon etc
du coup ça m'a un petit peu fait un
petit préjugés
juste avant le film et puis au final non
j'ai été bien surpris et j'ai bien aimé
non franchement j'ai bien aimé les
acteurs je trouvais tout le monde joue
et bien j'ai trouvé vraiment le film
sympa vachement bien quoi bon du coup
voilà que dire de plus dans le côté sans
spoil
alors évidemment vous vous en doutez et
cissé sur la bidane solo en solo on
connaît déjà son personnage
on connaît déjà tout ce qui appartient
solo toute fin son avenir et c'est son
amitié avec chewbacca le fait qu'il
travaille chez jabba etc etc
donc il ya plein de références à son
avenir qu'ils sont
plutôt bien amené mais je vous qui à
certains moments ça m'a fait un petit
peu voilà ça m'a fait un petit peu les
faits comme pirates des caraïbes 4
c'est à dire que voilà on retourne dans
le stage commence déjà dire voilà c'est
le bordel j'arrête pas de dire voilà
tout le temps ça m'énerve du coup des
empires des caraïbes 4 on est sur la vie
de jack sparrow et au temps présent et
puis dans le pirate des caraïbes 4 on
retourne dans son passé et cetera pas
voilà on va jack sparrow on sait qu'il a
son chapeau on sait qu'il a ses petits
trucs sur les cheveux lâchés ces jeux
j'ai je perds mes mots sa boussole etc
etc et ça m'a fait vraiment les faits un
peu de pirates des caraïbes cas c'est
que voilà on sait qu en solo il ya son
amitié avec chewbacca ya le faucon il
faut qu'on s'est un peu à part dans le
film quand même c'est un petit peu
amener plus tard il ya chewbacca il ya
son flingue son nom and and solo du coup
on à l'origine de son nom aussi et c'est
un petit peu je trouve à mener très vite
est vraiment enchaîner c'est vraiment
enchaîner à mener très vite toutes ces
histoires je ressens flammes sont sa
rencontre avec chewbacca son son son nom
parce qu'il fallait le mettre
j'ai vraiment eu cette impression c'est
vraiment pour moi le seul défaut du film
enfin non plus le gros défaut mais ce
qui m'a fait un petit peu picoter dans
le film est une autre chose mais je
pense qu'on y reviendra plus tôt dans la
partie spoil et voilà c'est ça m'a fait
vraiment les faits un peu ça a été un
peu l'effet genre boule de neige tac
non non on enchaîne tout et c'est mon à
mensah on enchaîne tout parce qu'il faut
le mettre parce que voilà ça appartient
de solofo le caser et puis voilà mais
sinon franchement c'était un très bon
film je m'attendais je vous dis je
m'attendais vraiment à rien et j'étais
franchement pas déçu en fait et je pense
que c'est comme ça que tu dois apprécier
un film parce qu'on se fait toujours un
pataquès pour star wars et ça fait
toujours de gros débats ça fait toujours
de grosses polémiques avec star wars
star wars 8 l'impression que les films
spin off au final sont les meilleurs
parce que du coup il ya c'est que du
bonus en fait c'est vraiment bon c'est
oui il ya le côté vraiment argent tout
ça et cetera évidemment et c'est
vraiment que du bonus et que du plus et
c'est bon à prendre
parce qu'on ne pourrait ne rien avoir je
le rappelle star wars c'était sans cesse
finir à l'épisode 6 et puis après
c'était fini
ils ont décidé de reprendre le truc le
flambeau alors après que on aime ou on
n'aime pas dans votre coeur si vous
aimez pas vous pouvez toujours vous
arrêter à la fin de l'épisode 6 mai
c'était franchement c'est franchement
que du bonus
et j'ai vraiment aimé
ce film plus que robben et voilà j'ai
rien à dire de plus c'est vraiment c'est
du bon quoi c'est du bon donc je vous
conseille vivement de le voir si vous ne
l'avez pas encore vue c'est vraiment un
très bon film voit maintenant passer la
partie spoil donc si vous n'avez pas vu
le film encore je vous conseille de
quitter la vidéo sinon
ben c'est votre responsabilité ne
m'accusez pas de spoil si vous n'avez
pas encore vu la partie spoil donc voilà
en solo on connaît son histoire
via l'univers un petit peu j'aurais
étant du genre lecture un petit peu de
ça j'avais lu son histoire et c'est sur
des sites certifiés cetera
mais le problème c'est que l'avis de m
sous l'eau il ya rien en fait de base
dedans je trouve genre voilà on sait qu
en solo il a raté son école de pilotage
que il a rencontré chewbacca qu'il a
gagné le faucon millenium tournoi de
sabac contre landeleau quel récipient et
son contrat avec jabba et c'est tout ce
qu'on sait au final et je trouvais que
c'était un petit peu à la base un film
sur rien et du coup j'y suis allé en
mode vraiment bon très bien disney
surprenez mois surprenez mois proposé -
un film star wars qui pourrait me plaire
et c'est sur un solo que je n'attendais
pas et que je n'attendais vraiment rien
j'y suis allé vraiment en mode je
n'attends rien je découvre et je pense
que du coup je me suis mis déjà et non
moins de pression parce qu'à chaque fois
que j'allais voir un film star wars
je sais qu'il avait la chaîne youtube
derrière et que vous m'attend deriez au
tournant pour des théories pour avoir
mon avis et cetera là dessus là je suis
un petit peu aller comme si j'y allais
pour moi en fait ce que du coup je suis
allé au ciné en plus je suis allé tout
seul et c'est comme si j'étais allé
vraiment pour moi c'était vraiment argot
rock solo story of luc gt gt aller tout
seul et c'était finalement c'était
vraiment bien je suis allé pour moi j'ai
pas regretter j'étais vraiment content
et puis j'ai trouvé que ma place de
cinéma était bien valait bien son prix
donc voila et au pied au final ils ont
amené plusieurs choses en plus etc qui
sont cool
alors partons tout va semer directement
d'accord je ne maîtrise pas tout ce qui
est canon et pas cannon
on apprend de ses erreurs je le note
donc je ne maîtrise pas tout ce qui est
canon etc
je ne sais pas vraiment ce qui est
qu'elles n'ont pas avec un solo et je
dis ça par rapport à la fin du film
donc comme je disais tout est amené un
petit peu enchaîné pour tous ses objets
fétiches et ccc
les points forts de han solo et mais le
film était vraiment cool du coup alors
il ya eu l'histoire du faucon millenium
bon orlando j'ai pas trouvé que c'était
j'ai bien aimé
le personnage etc mais j'ai pas trouvé
je sais pas je ne vais pas m'attendre à
ce type de landeleau en fait j'ai mangé
était un petit peu déçue de ce
personnage c'est le personnage qui m'a
le plus déçu entre guillemets mais au
final
enfin c'était pas non plus trop mais dix
ans mais voilà j'ai gelé vachement bien
aimé surtout le côté vraiment reflet à
en solo en fait je riais ressemble
vraiment à en solo et on sent une
certaine complicité entre les deux
personnages alors qu'ils se connaissent
pas du tout tout simplement parce qu'ils
se ressemblent et c'est vraiment très
agréable
donc cette histoire du faucon alors je
me rappelais pas clos avec tricher alors
je pense que ça car ajoutée pour le film
parce que du coup je me suis senti qu'on
est ça je trouve que c'était un peu bien
joué de la part de disney du coup parce
que vu qu'on connaît les fans
connaissent la vidéo en solo et qui a
pas non plus des choses incroyables
incroyable voilà on savait qu'ils
avaient leur l'école depuis l'automne et
cetera je veux pas me répéter mais du
coup là on s'est fait un peu avoir parce
que landau à gagner le premier tournoi
en trichant du coup et je m'y attendais
vraiment pas je suis d'accord bon ben
c'est bon ben il va voir le faucon à ce
moment là et les mille jouets ça trop
facile tu vois et puis au final c'était
vachement bien
bien tourné et cetera et cetera quoi et
puis au final à la fin du coup ils
retrouvent
landau pour le tournoi et puis là c'est
lui qui a réussi à l'avoir et puis là
c'est vraiment qu'ils font parce que
c'est dû en solo purquoi il est malin il
sait se débrouiller et puis au final il
à l'endos vraiment comme comme un saint
gilles il le massacre ou tournoi quoi il
est vraiment un chef
alors je pense un point débat aussi je
pense que c'est le
le personnage de alors c'est l3 je crois
je me souviens déjà plus du nom alors
j'ai vu le film là j'aurai une heure cl
3 je crois c'est du coup le robot qui
accompagne le dos et qui est vachement
un personnage dans les tendances
actuelles
rebellyon libéré et c'est un genre
féminisme et cetera et cetera
avec ce côté droid alors ça peut faire
pis côté je pense ça peut faire un petit
peu grincer des dents certains après ça
allait j'ai trouvé par contre que le
robot était enfin le droid était
beaucoup trop humaniser simple défaut de
star wars par normand journal qu'avec
r2d2 tout ça a été tellement habitués
mais là ce ce robot est vraiment en mode
trop humaniser en fait genre comment on
dit déjà personnalisé genre quand il dit
je sens votre regard et séraphin enfin
nantes est un robot quoi et puis ce bain
ce côté féminisme à moitié fin envers
les droïdes enfin j'veux pas comment
dire peut-être pas féministe mais voilà
défendre l'égalité des droits et sais
pas si c'est un peu féminisme droid
disent nous on va dire droid isme alors
je pense que ça peut faire grincer des
dents certains après ça joue sur les
tendances actuelles et c'est donc
c'était pas bête c'est j'ai trouvé ça
pas bête ça rendait le côté un petit
côté moderne à la chose mais au final
c'était c'était pas mal c'était c'était
pas mal je reste assez flou dans mes
arguments parce que je suis dans mes
pensées je sais pas trop collé en fait
j'arrive pas j'ai essayé d'écrire à un
peu ce que je voulais dire comme
argument pour le film mais j'arrive pas
faut vraiment que je le fasse de façon
naturelle que j'exprime ma pensée que
j'ai envie de vous dire sur ce film et
surtout les autres à chaque fois j'ai
vraiment besoin d'y aller comme ça au
film du coup c'est pour ça alors six
points un petit peu négatif c'est la
relation avec keira voilà qui aura bon
c'est mia clarke et ou alors un média
clark moi je suis comme un dingue j'ai
le coeur
j'ai le coeur comme as à chaque fois que
je vois emilia clarke que je suis fou
d'elle je suis comme un dingue
du coup on est dans une relation
amoureuse avec un solo donc ça je trouve
ça joue vachement bien sur le côté en
plus
jeunesse et ses deux en solo parce que
du coup c'est un mec voilà il est en
couple avec keira c'est un peu un couple
de jeunesse et puis ils sont pleins de
rêves et ses rivales équilibre ils
veulent avoir leur vaisseau faire les
quatre coins de la galaxie etc
et dès le début on est face à une
relation forte et une relation qu'on
apprécie et cetera et puis qui après a
été je trouve un petit peu bafouée en
fait genre c'est le problème je pense
aussi des films et le problème surtout
parce qu'il fallait garder un mystère
pour keira et cetera du suspense mais je
trouve que ça a été trop bafoués en fait
parce que du coup on sait on sait dès le
début du film que anne son but ultime
c'est de retrouver keira et de s'en
aller avec elle pour nous voilà c'est
utile mais tu sais il va la retrouver
soit la fin soit au milieu du film
enfin on sait qu'il va la retrouver et
que du coup il va avoir des choses à se
dire
parce que nous sommes trois quatre ans
après qu'il ait dû partir de corellia et
que l ai dû rester et le malheureusement
à chaque fois toutes les scènes où ils
doivent parler son coupé il ya même
moment en plus au moins trois quatre
scènes comme ça jean louis even saw ou
en solo il veut parler etc
ils veulent qu'ils échangent sur leur
passé et encore et encore on sait dès
fois il
l'impression qui n'est même pas curieux
quoi et à chaque fois c'est couper à
chaque fois c'est reporté et c est ça
c'est un côté très frustrant et pas du
tout je trouve assez réelle en fait
parce que quand tu es amoureux de
quelqu'un que vous êtes séparés
brutalement et que vous vous retrouvez
que vous aimez toujours et des choses à
se dire il ya des choses à mettre sur la
table qu'est-ce que tu es devenu
pourquoi comment comment ça se fait et c
est ça ça a été tellement je trouve
bafoués que en plus au final ils sont
même plus vraiment amoureux en fait
c'est vraiment un petit peu un amour
caché et gens comme s'ils étaient déjà
devenus adultes etc
et j'ai trouvé ça vraiment frustrant ce
côté on ne se dit rien on laisse faire
les choses et puis au final pas un
soldat istra il se fait trahir comme
comme une merde voilà et c'est alors
qu'il aurait pu mais du poing sur la
table et parler avec elle puisque il
l'aimait puisqu'il voulait partir avec
elle et c'est enfin je fasse si vous
comprenez ma pensée j'ai trouvé ce côté
vraiment fruste rond par rapport au film
à ce qu'on voulait en savoir plus et au
final ça a été négligée et s'acheter un
petit peu un petit peu déçue a jugé un
petit peu amer là dessus je reste un peu
sur ma faim sur cette relation surtout
du coup dès le début du film j'avais
intégré pour moi keira devait mourir
comme tous les personnages introduits
que kiara devait mourir parce que tout
simplement on ne la voit pas
dans les star wars etc sauf que là du
coup et survie et celle à des fins
d'ailleurs falloir débattre là dessus
enfin je le faut que je m'en vais dans
mes paroles mais je lui dis ce que je
veux dire qu'on va attaquer directement
là dessus le caméo
voilà donc c'était évident à voir les
spin off 1 c'est maintenant juste avec
un film on habitue et qu'il y aura un
caméo forcément à la fin du film
un gros caméo donc je savais qu'ils
allaient avoir un gros truc à la fin du
film je me disais bon on va voir soit 1
va d'or soit quelques quelqu'un comme ça
soit ainsi dios etc
et du coup nous sommes face à un dark
maul revenus des abysses et j'ai été
très surpris et j'étais très content
alors c'est là qu'il faut à floirac
qu'on débatte ensemble parce que du coup
voilà c'est par rapport à ça je voulais
dire par rapport à keira là ce skiset
cet appel de dark maul lasser c'est ce
retour de dark maul signifie que
l'univers étendu et pris en compte alors
on savait déjà que l'univers étendu été
un petit peu pris en compte alors j'ai
pas envie que l'île du débat ou du trash
talk etc etc
par rapport à ce qui est canon ou pas
voilà dark maul dans les films
il est mort dans le bain en fait
alors après il ya eu clone wars et c'est
un rail ou star wars rebels
bon j'ai pas vu tout ça et c'est dark
maul est censé mourir voilà dans l'un il
est mort dans l'ain après l'univers
étendu l'a fait survivre voilà dark maul
a réussi à survivre et c'est s'est
fabriqué des jambes mécanique pour
pouvoir s'enfuir et est retourné sur sa
planète d'origine
je sais plus laquelle je vous cache pas
que je me souviens plus des noms et
qu'il retrouve sa mère pareil dont j'ai
oublié totalement le nom qui lui a fait
de vrais jambes robotique pour pouvoir
se redéplacer comme avant quoi est il a
fondé du coup je ne me souviens plus non
plus du nom en retrouvant son frère
hasard vendresse me souviens du nom pour
pouvoir renverser l'empereur parce que
du coup dark maul s'est senti trahi par
rapport à l'empereur et il veut sa
vengeance en tant que bons gros sites
des familles et du coup il va monter
quelque chose avec son frère qui va très
mal tourner puisque l'empereur bas
battue et le frère de dark maul et en
combat de sabre laser et va épargner
dark maul parce que c'était son apprenti
qu'il a toujours respecté etc
et puis au final du coup dark maul
moeurs face à obi wan imsand dans
rebelles définitivement là il meurt
c'est fini mais voilà tout ça c'était du
dessin animé s'était pas vraiment canon
puis c'est devenu alors je sais pas si
c'est devenu vraiment canon etc
mais je pense que ça l'est devenu je me
suis pas trop pencher là dessus je sais
que c'est un défaut que vous me
reprochez très souvent mais j'ai pas
géré s'empalant vie en fait de me
plonger là dedans parce que j'ai eu
beaucoup de pas de griefs mais j'ai fait
une overdose de star wars un peu avec un
moment est de savoir celle de ce que
star wars c'est ce qui m'a fait décoller
un petit peu et c'est bien un certain
moment je me suis un peu enfermé dans
des vidéos star wars ne savait plus trop
rien à dire mais j'avais fait un petit
peu une pause but survenu avec star wars
8 et je me suis dit on va juste parler
star wars 8
j'ai pas trop envie de dire des choses
pour le moment et on parlera de star
wars 9 mai plus tard en temps voulu et
du coup il ya eu un solo qui a été
prévenue me suis dit ah bon on parlera
de vannes solo qu'il y aura à le solo
alors du coup on en parle aujourd'hui et
caetera et
voilà j'ai eu pas mal de problèmes un
peu avec la communauté star wars etc qui
sont vraiment à fond sur star wars sur
ce qui est canon ce qui ne l'est pas je
pense par rapport aux 6 à 6 bat la
dernière vidéo star wars que j'avais
fait
où ça a été un peu une erreur de ma part
sans être une erreur je ne regrette pas
cette vidéo mais je regrette le côté un
peu le côté un peu plus ta clique que
j'ai fait sans devoir j'ai vraiment fait
un côté qu à cliquer sur cette vidéo
sans m'en rendre compte et je m'en suis
rendu compte vraiment récemment que
cette vidéo pouvait être
un peu mensongères et c est tout ça
parce que je voulais débattre faire des
théories sur du coup tout ce qui a été
révélé sur snow parce que ce n'est que
c'est pareil ça touche un peu à
l'univers étendu au final où ça parle de
dark bane etc etc
et mme est empli beaucoup pas mal de
foudres des fans de star wars
j'ai toujours eu ce côté défensif
ce côté coquille face aux fans de star
wars ou à chaque fois je me défendrai
dans les commentaires ou j'ignorais et
parce que ça me saoulait en fait à
chaque fois je voulais juste exprimer
mon avis sur star wars partager une
passion que j'ai pour star wars parce
que j'adore star wars et du coup je me
prenais des foudres parfois des fans et
caetera et ça me franchement ça me
faisait chier et du coup j'avais ce côté
défensif et je pense que du coup faire
une pause laisser un peu de côté star
wars et c'est un peu me joue t etc
ça m'a fait prendre en compte certaines
choses et je n'ai pas de regrets mais je
veux plus me professionnaliser dans
ce travail
de recherche etc parce que j'ai toujours
fait mes théories à ma façon
comme je le pense avec deux trois idées
piochées sur internet et c'est dans mes
recherches pour m'inspirer pour les
théories etc et des fois ça m'est arrivé
de dire des grosses conneries tu sais je
m'étais ça sur l'excusé de la théorie
mais il faut que je fasse plus de
recherche et c'est plus un travail de
recherche et du coup je regrette un
petit peu ceci et je veux vraiment prêt
me professionnaliser là dessus mais le
côté voilà l'univers étendu star wars
bloque un peu elle ce que j'arrive pas à
regarder clone wars ou star wars
rebelles ça m'attire pas du tout et j'ai
pas envie de me forcer donc
voilà voilà parenthèse fermée en a fait
grosse parenthèse ça fait du bien de se
confier un petit peu je veux j'espère
que vous aurez compris ma pensée
retourneront caméo donc du coup ceci
amène l'univers étendu qui a toujours
été un petit peu bafouée un petit peu
mis de côté non c'est pas canon les
films c'est ça et ça c'est du c'est du
rêve c'est du plus c'est pas important
du coup la dark maul et à mener donc ça
veut dire que c'est forcément après star
wars 1
parce que l'udc a à peu près le même âge
qu'eux en solo enfin il est un peu plus
jeune mais voilà il doit être boutonneux
on va dire là où pendant que en solo il
fait son star wars story et du coup ça
se passe forcément après star wars
parce que du coup sec anakin et ses
acolytes et mômes donc très loin luc et
c'est donc je sais même pas pourquoi je
parle l'udc donc ça veut dire que dark
maul a survécu en voie de retour j'ai
d'ailleurs je j'ai hésité à me demander
si c'était vraiment d'arc mots je me
suis dit c'est peut-être son frère ou
autres parce que du coup on le voyait
mais on le reconnaissait pas trop alors
je me suis dit mais en même temps après
son combat il a été bien bien amoché et
la chose que je regrette mais que
non je le regrette pas parce qu'au final
je pense là bien avoir vu ces légendes
mécanique
il a vraiment les gens de mécanique
parce que justement quand je entendu la
voix je suis où on va être face à un
empereur style sidious etc va être face
à quelqu'un de très important et je
reconnaissais pas la voie et je suis non
c'est pas si douce
du coup j'ai regardé attentivement et
puis la joie des gens de mécanique je me
fais avoir à ça doit être un personnage
à mener et c est la joie dark maul
donc du coup c'est vraiment le dark maul
de l'univers étendu qui a survécu qui a
les jambes mécanique et c'est ouf qu'ils
amènent de l'univers étendu comme ça
dans star wars je suis choquée là dessus
alors du coup ça m'amène justement un
kira kira je ne sais pas c'est qui je
pense que c'est un personnage à mener
pour le film mais est-ce que keira au
final n'est pas une période une personne
un personnage déjà connu de star wars
n'hésitez pas à me dire dans un
commentaire d'ailleurs ils ont tout à me
dire ce que vous avez pensé du film etc
et du coup que voilà ça peut rajouter
des trucs parfois l'univers étendu mais
le problème c'est que du coup on sait
pas on la voit pas dans les autres films
alors c'est un peu dérangeant là dessus
en tout cas c'était un gros caméo et ça
fait plaisir de voir l'univers étendu
rajouter parce que c'est à dire qu'ils
peuvent se permettre beaucoup plus de
choses et cohérente en plus ça en
les choses encore plus cohérente et ça
franchement ça fait vachement plaisir de
voir dark maul donc voilà j'ai rien à
dire de plus là dessus et c'était
vachement cool je pense ne pas avoir
grand chose à dire de plus sur le film
ce que je suis vraiment allé en mode je
n'attendais rien j'avais peur de dire la
phrase de louis dans malcolm
je ne m'attendais à rien je suis quand
même déçu et au final non je ne
m'attendais à rien et je suis très très
content du rendu du film j'ai vraiment
apprécié et je vous conseille vraiment
de le voir si je vous dis ça je dis
c'est qu'on se dise ça là parce que je
pense que vous l'avez vu mais ça m'a
fait plaisir alors maintenant pour les
théories je vous cache pas que je ne
sais pas trop j'ai pas franchement
d'idées théorie parce que c'est une
histoire du passé on connaît déjà
l'avenir seuls keira est un petit peu un
mystère pour moi à mes yeux dans le film
donc voilà je après avoir avec vous
dites moi si vous voulez vraiment
détérioré dans les commentaires mais je
vous avoue que moi surtout par rapport à
moi je n'ai pas spécialement guider
après je suis pas obligé faire un trois
théories je peux en faire qu'une si j'ai
une idée théorie je vous la
partageraient bien évidemment mais voilà
en tout cas je vous remercie d'avoir
suivi cette vidéo je suis très content
de vous l'avoir fait je suis très
content de pouvoir débattre et goût de
partager sur les films et où je kiffe
hertz à partager mon avis sur les films
et débattre avec vous cet argot rock
écoutez je vous fais des gros bisous que
le alors du coup on me l'a dit dans les
commentaires que le 'lion' art soit avec
vous mais bon même si c'est je préfère
dire lionheart ouais enfin bref je
m'égare s'était targuée recalés de shao
tout le monde c'était vachement cool
[Musique]